yes daily from science mission prolonged
fasting promote stress resistance but
its effects on longevity are poorly
understood alternating prolonged fasting
and nutrient rich medium extended East
life span independently of established
Pro longevity genes that mimicking
fasting rejuvenates the immune system
there is as cancer incidence remorse
hippocampal neurogenesis and improves
cognitive performance in mice in a pilot
human clinical trial three diet
mimicking fasting cycles in decreased
risk factors biomarkers for aging
diabetes cardiovascular disease and
cancer providing support for the
periodic fasting cycles to promote
health span next authors in the journal
Nature showed that under normal
conditions fructose is metabolized in
the liver by an enzyme keto hexokinase
see all other cells normally have khk a
isoform which does not metabolize
fructose very well during stressful
conditions like increased VP are during
hypoxia in heart hypoxia-inducible
factor levels go up which in turn
activates splicing factor called sf3 b1
the set 3 B 1 increases khk sea levels
that metabolizes third toes in the heart
providing energy and this worsening the
heart condition auto show that blocking
fructose metabolism or decreasing
fructose intake could decrease
heart-related diseases by fretting on
energy supply for more news visitors at
www since mission calm or science
mission Facebook page thanks for
watching